yesterday governor steve sisolak
announced nevada's statewide pause
is staying in place and at the same time
he restarted the eviction moratorium to
try and help those struggling homeowners
and renters across the state
bianca holman is live this morning with
more details on the statewide pause
bianca
good morning john lakovid 19
hospitalizations and deaths
definitely have continued since that
statewide pause happened
three weeks ago and actually those
numbers are higher and so governor
sislak he has decided to extend
that pause into the new year now here's
what that means for everybody at home
the pause will be extended through
january 15th at the earliest
this includes restrictions on capacity
limits at restaurants and casinos
to 25 percent private gatherings are
limited to 10 people and no more than
two households
both indoors and outdoors public
gatherings are limited to 50 people or
25 percent of the capacity whichever is
less
governor sysolak warned that he would
have to tighten restrictions if our
coven numbers
don't get better but i need to be clear
if officials and experts agree that our
trends are going beyond our ability to
respond
i will be forced to come in front of you
all again with tougher actions
i believe we can avoid those actions if
we all commit to it
the governor also says that shutting
down the entire state is quote
unrealistic
he blamed congress for not providing
additional support and said our families
and neighborhoods they really need the
support right now
and also the governor has said that he
will be calling on washington
for more help as we get through this
time period reporting live from umc
bianca holman 8 news now